oh
alors moi j'ai une sérieuse addiction
pour les documentaires animaliers en
2010 j'habitais à londres
j'étudiais le design et je regardais
beaucoup la bbc je suis tombé sur une
émission sur les dix espèces les plus
surprenantes
je me souviens il y avait les termites
les coraux les baleines aussi et parmi
tous à un petit oiseau qui vit en
australie son nom en aborigènes c'est le
8 à l'orthographe un peu bizarre je vous
accorde mais lui aussi un peu bizarre
mais un peu cinglé même l'air de rien ce
tout petit oiseau fait des choses
incroyables et il est polygame
son truc à lui c'est de draguer un
maximum de femelles le truc c'est qu'il
est pas très beau il n'a pas de
magnifiques plumes colorées par exemple
par contre il est artiste designer et
décorateur d'intérieur sont ni c'est une
espèce de grottes posé au sol fait de
brindilles mais aussi de fruits de
fleurs et de coquillages il utilise
aussi de la mousse et des champignons
comme de la moquette pour tapisser le
fond de sa grotte ça lui dit qu'il est
un peu cinglé ensuite il va se mettre au
fond de son lit et chante
vous pouvez pas penser à un personnage
de santé de science-fiction - il faut
penser aux petits r2d2 son nid c'est un
super amplificateur j'ai en fait et tout
ça c'est un magnifique décor de théâtre
alors vous demandez peut-être pourquoi
je vous parle d'un oiseau le lien avec
l'optimisme
tout simplement parce que notre rythme a
un gros problème
le même que le nôtre plastique paille
bush ont envahi son environnement mais
lui ça semble lui convenir
il a appris à réutiliser le plastique et
sa stratégie de séduction marche même
encore mieux depuis
il a amélioré son taux de conquête
depuis l'âge du plastique
merci la révolution industrielle alors
on pourrait dire que le wita a su
transformer des contraintes en
opportunités
il a su innover avec toutes les
ressources de son environnement
il s'est adapté aux changements cette
rencontre avec 8 ha avec ce petit génie
de la nature m'a rendu optimiste et elle
m'a permis d'avancer à un moment où
j'avais envie de me rendre utile et de
rendre le fonctionnement de notre
société plus durable
le wita m'a inspiré la création d'une
entreprise parce que sa stratégie
appliquée notre économie nous incite à
considérer tout ce qui nous entoure
comme des ressources à faire disparaître
la notion même de déchets et optimiser
toutes les ressources locales et ça nous
permet d'entrevoir la possibilité d'un
modèle véritablement durable
j'ai une super nouvelle pour vous cette
nouvelle économie existe déjà
elle a même un nom elle s'appelle
l'économie circulaire évidemment ça
tranche avec notre modèle actuel
profondément linéaire ou d'un côté on
utilise de plus en plus les ressources
de notre planète qui sont limités et
donc super précieuses et de l'autre on
génère de plus en plus de déchets qui
s'accumulent et polluent notre
environnement
alors que dans la nature les déchets
n'existe pas vraiment tout est une
ressource potentielle pour un autre
individu
les matériaux sont biodégradables
ça aide alors que nous humains nous qui
sont des matériaux qui ne se décomposent
pas toujours et qui ne peuvent pas
circuler facilement d'une entité une
autre du coup les preuves s'accumulent
alors c'est vrai vous allez me dire vrai
en france c'est bon on fait le tri qui
fait le tri par exemple ici dans cette
salle c'est très bien je m'attendais
c'est très bien le tri le recyclage il
faut le faire évidemment c'est très
important mais c'est pas la solution
miracle
on arrive à recycler que 30 % des
déchets ça veut dire qu'on continue à
bazarder a cramé ou à balancer leurs les
océans 70% de tout le reste c'est
vraiment débile comme truc non
la terre c'est notre capital commun de
départ à tous un peu notre compte en
banque et on perd à tout jamais 70 % de
toutes ces précieuses ressources
j'ai pas vous mais moi j'essaie de gérer
un peu mieux au compte en banque on peut
faire différemment certains essayent de
faire différemment et de repenser des
systèmes vertueux aux philippines par
exemple les océans sont ravagés par des
filets de pêche abandonnés
c'est catastrophique une entreprise paye
aujourd'hui des pêcheurs pour récupérer
ses filets et elle re fabrique du fil de
moquette avec imaginer une action trois
bénéfices ont créé un produit rentable
on multiplie les sources de revenus pour
les pêcheurs et on dépollue la mer moi
c'était mon rêve ce genre de trucs des
solutions sans impact négatif uniquement
des effets positifs
alors j'ai cherché à comprendre comment
reproduire ce type d' approche qui
associe bénéfices économiques
environnementaux et sociétaux et plus
que le design de simples produits objets
c'était ça qui me semble être le vrai
bon design
au début j'ai cherché les solutions de
manière frénétique en détournant les
dix-sept entreprises
en fouillant dans leur belle pour
fabriquer d'autres objets le problème
avec tout ça c'est que c'était toujours
en réaction au problème finalement
confronté à la limite du recyclage on
arrive à recycler les objets les
matériaux une deux fois puis après ça
revient des déchets mais en prenant le
problème à la source
j'ai fini par trouver la solution en
m'intéressant aux ressources
dès le départ j'ai découvert qu'on peut
concevoir des produits et des services
écologiques ou les déchets des uns
peuvent devenir les ressources des
autres
c'est ça le vrai recyclage intégré comme
dans la nature et les écosystèmes qui
nous entoure et là j'ai compris que les
solutions inspirante et innovantes sont
tout autour de nous
la nature nous a pas attendu pour
innover elle fait de la recherche et
développement la r&d comme on dit depuis
l'apparition de la vie sur terre il ya
presque 4 milliards d'années c'est pas
rien moi je me suis inspiré du 8a mais
vous aussi vous pouvez vous inspirer du
monde vivant il ya de quoi faire et même
en réfléchissant au fonctionnement de
votre propre organisme et de vos
cellules
pensez aux collaborations qui se
produisent entre vos cellules et les
bactéries qui habite votre système
digestif
c'est un axe un écosystème absolument
prodigieux là aussi et qui pourraient
nous apprendre plein de choses sur
l'écologie l'économie circulaire mais
aussi la communication où l'adaptation
au changement lorsque nous mangeons
nouveaux aliments par exemple et si on
reparle de ressources
vous savez que l'uriné est complètement
sous-estimé
vous rigolez mais des scientifiques
essaient de créer de l'énergie avec en
utilisant son hydrogène qui est deux
fois plus concentrée abondante dans
l'eau et donc deux fois plus rentable à
extraire mais aujourd'hui on continue à
gâcher cette ressource car on la mélange
à l'eau de toilette elle est diluée elle
perd son potentiel
les ressources les énergies ne sont pas
rares en réalité il en existe plein le
soleil mais aussi la géothermie et
pourquoi pas la gravité qui est une
force encore plus grande et totalement
omnisciente j'active les marais en
permanence sur l'ensemble du globe grâce
à la collaboration terre-lune
si on pense vraiment global si on pense
même plus grand à les galactiques à la
danse des planètes au fonctionnement de
l'univers on se rend compte qu'il ya
encore plein de solutions potentielles
pour nos besoins et si on pense tout
petit au niveau moléculaire maintenant
et encore plein de solutions une
entreprise s'inspire du fonctionnement
physico-chimiques des coraux pour
capturer le trop-plein de co2 en gros
grâce à l'eau de mer elles capturent le
carbone le transforme en ciment et des
polluent l'atmosphère
ça aussi c'est génial parce que le
ciment le béton et la construction en
général sont les industries qui
dépensent le plus de matières premières
et d'énergie dans le monde
alors vous allez dire ok merci nicolas
physico-chimiques les coraux on sert
bien compliqué tout ça comment on peut
faire à notre niveau
au niveau local peut faire plein de
choses
au danemark la ville de kalundborg a
initié depuis plusieurs décennies déjà
une transition pour mutualiser toutes
les ressources des entreprises et de la
ville par exemple la chaleur des usines
et réutilisées pour le chauffage urbain
mais il ya aussi tout un écosystème de
fer mutualiser et ça s'inspire du
fonctionnement très efficient des forêts
alors ce qui est très surprenant est
assez unique
c'est que dans cet écosystème déjà on se
parle on considère l'interdépendance des
choses ça s'appelle le design
collaboratif et ça crée de la valeur et
de l'innovation en permanence ça a
permis de rendre cet écosystème très
résilient
c'est à dire que si nos ressources se
met à manquer le système peut se
réorganiser ce design collaboratif
permet de mobiliser tout le potentiel du
système il est économique
on réduit le gâchis au maximum on
améliore la qualité de vie aussi en
produisant des aliments locaux et ont
réduit la pollution
cette approche qui considère le
bien-être pour les êtres humains
la viabilité économique
la faisabilité technologique et la
cohérence avec le contexte naturel local
c'est ça qu'il faut reproduire et design
et comme on dit alors comment on fait
pour comprendre son écosystème ses
ressources et les flux qui existe c'est
la compliquer quand même nous on a eu
l'idée de créer un jeu un jeu
collaboratif simples comme le monopoly
que vous connaissez tous sauf que tout
le monde gagne à la fin
car il repose sur les principes de co
création et facilite le dialogue aussi
et nous permet de prendre conscience que
nous sommes tous acteurs
vous êtes tous acteurs de cette nouvelle
économie
ce design collaboratif
nous donne aussi le pouvoir de
redessiner tous ensemble un nouveau
monde où l'homme l'économie et la nature
sont réconciliés alors j'aimerais vous
donner envie vous aussi d'innover selon
ses lois de la nature et de rentrer en
empathie avec elle vous et vous inviter
à trouver votre oiseau vos tweets à pour
vous reconnecter avec la nature car je
suis sûr que vous trouverez des réponses
et des solutions aspirante innovantes et
passionnante dans le monde vivant quel
que soit votre sujet par exemple la
commune i si vous inspirer de la
communication décentralisée chez les
fourmis ou les termites ou la
transmission du savoir chez les
éléphants où les baleines ou encore de
ce réseau coopératif qui existe sous nos
pieds entre les champignons les plantes
et les arbres
il est temps de nous reconnecter à tous
ces génies caché qui nous entoure nous
habite pour évoluer à prendre tous
ensemble et prospérer en harmonie avec
les lois de l'univers